we're out here in Cincinnati Ohio with
my boy Tommy Cramer number one recruit
in the 2016 class in the state of Ohio
Notre Dame commit we're in Izzie's
restaurant we're gonna take down the
five pound
Reuben sandwich ready do it let's get
after it
[Music]
this is ridiculous are you gonna go
about it I don't even know what I think
I'm gonna take the bun off and attack
the meat see how I'm feeling then get
back to the bus straight meet the star
great meat they're gonna go potato
oh yeah just cut it up so substance and
then we'll work on the bun app yep
that's the point when I go with that -
three two one
I mean that's a dent all right yeah I'm
sure bubbling you know what I want which
sounds weird but I want more potato a
little less sauerkraut so did you do
anything to prepare for this
I didn't eat for the past 24 hours to
get ready for the Sun I have not eaten
since four o'clock yesterday
we're guy like you know yeah it's tough
right it was really tough all right five
minutes in will check mine out first
I'm out like a third way so I'm I'm
above average right now I'm drying it
but we got a human vacuum over here I'm
about halfway through where are you
you're officially six five three what
about 310 Jeff - this probably three 20
you got 20 minutes laughter you think
you'll be able to do it we'll see I
think I think the buns gonna be a
problem
that's about a pound of bun feeling good
slowing down a little bit it's getting
to me a little bit yep
hitting the wall 15 minutes Oh dropping
out my mouth now I'm losing everything
motor skills I'm struggling very hard
Tommy over here how you doing not bad
let's put a meet left right here right
here we got the meat done now we're
going straight bread and sauerkraut five
minutes to see if you can do it
how you feeling we're coming down to the
end here kind of hitting the wall
spirits were high going into the head
and then the sandwiches just mentally
broken both of a sound
all right last 15 seconds I'm grinding
away let's get it done
[Music]
there you have it couldn't take it down
unbelievable effort me not so much we
Came we saw we got conquered